en Europe le rôle de la recherche
publique et très fort dans les
technologies émergentes je parlais du
quantique les les talents qu'on voit
émerger et les technologies de rupture
qui sont développées en Europe dans le
cantique émergent à partir d'organismes
publics par exemple en France le CEA ou
l'université Paris-Saclay je
mentionnerai à des jeunes pousses comme
Alison Bob et Pascal qui sont vraiment
au niveau
plus élevé de la recherche et
technologies au niveau mondial
aujourd'hui au sein de l'Union
européenne la question se pose pas on
coopère dans la recherche quand bien
même on serait concurrent économique
mais au-delà de l'Europe évidemment la
question se pose d'une autre manière les
États-Unis ça a été un peu évoqué par
par Louis
sont dans une ambiguïté de
positionnement puisqu'ils à la fois
conserver leur domination technologique
mondiale notamment dans le cadre de la
rivalité avec la Chine tout en étant
dans une approche partenariale ce qui
crée des certains une certaine ambiguïté
une difficulté à fonder des partenariats
de recherche avec les États-Unis
notamment aussi du fait que la puissance
de la recherche universitaire américaine
et son attractivité crée des asymétries
très significatives en termes de moyens
et plus encore les États-Unis ont
tendance à attirer y compris les talents
européens par ailleurs du côté américain
le capitalisme politique est évidemment
libéral et très centré sur le secteur
privé et le secteur privé lui-même les
gafam notamment les entreprises
initialement du numérique qui produisent
des logiciels sont de plus en plus
investis dans des technologies
émergentes y compris des technologies
matérielles de hardware y compris dans
des domaines tels que le quantique de
mentionné tout à l'heure Amazon
IBM Google développe des ordinateurs
quantiques aujourd'hui
tout comme il développe aussi évidemment
dans le cas d'Amazon notamment des
systèmes satellites des câbles
sous-marins etc
or ces grandes entreprises privées ne
sont pas dans l'obligation de publier
leurs recherches donc on a des
situations où Alison Bob spinov de la
recherche publique française publie ses
résultats et son concept d'ordinateur
quantique
et Amazon développe un concept
d'ordinateur quantique sur la base de
cette recherche publiée par cette
start-up française on a donc une
asymétrie des acteurs et de leurs
pratiques qui posent question